it is scary and hard to run your own
race
and a lot of people will doubt you along
the way and tell you that it's not
possible even if it's in the loving way
it's not possible that you can't do it
and we often then lead the doubt in
ourselves and that voice comes in and
says that we can't do it and so the
answer is to start to shift the
environment to start to eliminate the
people who are creating those negative
thoughts around this to start to try to
get some mentors to help teach and learn
to try to join a community of people who
are just as ambitious as we are trying
to accomplish great things and to be
around the content of people who Inspire
us to want to go off and be amazing